what do you think is the biggest
misconception about benny the butcher
damn
the biggest misconception without me let
me think about this one because it's a
good question
oh man
i don't i don't understand i don't think
people understand that
how hard i had to work for this [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying like i come in with
wes i come in with car way i don't think
a lot of people understand that i
that i i
put put aside a lot of [ __ ] i got to
work so hard for this [ __ ] i don't think
i don't know man it's not just a whole
bunch of [ __ ] i don't think people
really understand that
you know i came from i came from that
cloth i was 18 in federal prison i was
going to say you came from being in
prison not knowing you know what i'm
saying like people understand that you
know what i mean because not saying that
these dudes these
guys and my peers they never done that
because we all just said we all be doing
that not glorifying enough but
you know i'm i'm i'm a real member not
saying that
i'm the toughest army because that's
that's not what i stand on but
i'm a real member man you know my mom my
eight kids
my main single mom
been through foster homes
and i mean and just just with that i'm
not a [ __ ] who got lucky with a song
you know what i mean like works man
exactly so it's like all of that
and and i studied this [ __ ]
and i mean i studied how to get on
because i didn't you know i said
everything fell into place but i studied
like
like rapping i always listened to this
[ __ ] i wrote bars down other rappers i'm
saying just basically like i supposed to
be here and i'm a person we got here
like purely from the work from the work
not no luck [ __ ] no nothing and
sacrifice
exactly because i can only imagine being
like perceived as like
you know when gunn and conway were going
to those stations and you would rap
this time i mean you got children bro
like you're a grown-ass man you ain't
some kid who ain't got [ __ ]
responsibilities and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
ain't paying you at the moment
that's a fact that's a lot of sacrifice
man i
i remember telling i remember because i
always held it down for my kids they
always call and ask for [ __ ] i remember
when i was
really about to
buckle down to do this
i had they was calling me had to
tell their mom like yo let them have a
talk with them and let them know like
they can't be called me asking me for
[ __ ] right now because i'm focusing on
some things i'm going through something
because i i didn't want to tell them but
they needed to know you know what i'm
saying so they eased up off me
uh she told them and i'm saying in about
like six months it was it was i was back
in a position where i was doing [ __ ] for
him but like but it took like you had to
like real [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean
that's [ __ ] crazy